foreign
all right
remember to do that feel free to remind
me
I also have to talk quietly because
people turn people turn and face to
slides
but the microphone fixes that no no
the microphone is very Direction because
I noticed it you can try to look at the
sides
and then you can't hear them because
you're awake
okay
hi everyone good morning
so this is going to be a talk at
basically it's a combination of two
different results
um on two different problems and the
unifying technique is the unifying theme
is one technique that we call congestion
violencing and the technique is really
what I want to highlight
S Talk
first part is about matching
so we've seen this problem many times
already in this week so in this
particular setting we're going to assume
a bipartite graph
and the address here just Elites 100 at
a time so say the graph is unweighted
you could make this work for weighted
graphs and the goal is to maintain a one
minus Epsilon approximate matching
so note that maintaining an exact
matching is hard so you really need this
one minus Epsilon proximation
so what we show is to do this very
efficiently in polylog update time and
we later extend this to non-by-priced
as well so I'm just going to very
quickly talk about the background I'm
not going to talk about all of the
backgrounds I'm matching I think uh like
David and Sohail have already done a lot
of that
um but just the direct contrast to our
work is an incremental result similar
even better constant update time was
known before
but the fully Dynamic case is very hard
if you want like a one minus subplot
approximation you need something like
update time or you can do a tiny bit
better if you only care about the size
of the matching
so basically what we're able to show is
like okay both decremental and
incremental are easy and it seems to
only be their combinations
okay so now let's talk about how we get
this and again the main thing I want to
highlight is the technique also this
result is very simple this is like five
self-contained pages in a paper so I'm
basically going to go through the whole
thing and you should stop me if
something isn't making sense because if
it's not making sense it's not because
there's I'm sweeping something complex
under the rugged just because I'm not
explaining it well so please feel free
okay
um yes so for this part as I said this
is two talks and it's literally two
talks
um I'm gonna switch it here
um
you will note that
chupal is orange and not me
and that's because I kept that to
highlight that this is mostly his slides
some minor changes but these slides are
mostly due to him from a previous talk
okay
all right so
thank you
so again this is the problem you want to
maintain a bipartite matching in a
decremental setting
and in particular to solve this problem
it's enough to solve the following
slightly simpler problem
um
which is that basically in linear time
you're told you have some matching of
size mu that's your max matching so
um and your goal is just to keep track
of a matching of size approximately mu
or detect that the maximum matching size
has fallen significantly so when the
maximum matching size Falls
significantly you don't have to compute
a new matching you just say okay I
terminate the maximum Matrix as follows
and it's pretty clear if you can solve
the subroutine you can solve the whole
problem you just whatever the maximum
matching size Falls you go again so this
cruelly this crucially uses the fact
that the update sequence is decremental
so the matching size is only falling and
this sort of new phase can only happen
like login times
come from now and we start with the
Maxima matching size mu and we want to
maintain a large matching size mu or say
there's no large matching anymore
are we maintaining the the matching or
just the size the matching we are
maintaining them
but the question is what is thank you
are we maintaining the matching or just
the size of the matching we're
maintaining the matching exclusively
okay so let's try some things that don't
work but they're going to lead us to the
final solution so the first thing you
want to try is let's just be lazy
so the nice thing about a matching is
that it's quite stable if you delete a
single edge that can only change the
matching value by one
so our algorithm is we're going to
compute a matching
and then we're just going to wait for
like Epsilon times the size of the
matching deletions we just do nothing
because the matching cannot change that
much after that many deletions maybe our
matching isn't good anymore so we
recompute
that's the whole lazy algorithm
and it's clear this is always a good
approximation because you don't because
matching is robust and so
okay the problem with this is that it's
too slow you're gonna have to recompute
too many times
so let's see that in more detail
so let's say the original graph is
actually just a complete graph
and the adversary is always going to use
the same strategy which is whatever
matching you pick they're just going to
delete the edges of that matching
so you start with a complete graph and
some matching diversary is going to
delete the edges of your matching now
you have an almost complete graph
so you picked another matching the
address is going to delete those edges
now you have something that's still
pretty close to a complete graph and
this can just keep going and the
adversary can clearly end up causing you
to recompute a new matching end times
but recomputing a new matching costs m
so you have MN total update time where
we would like M total update
okay so this lazy approach doesn't work
why it doesn't work basically the issue
is this is that your graph has N squared
edges
the matching that you care about has n
and so by Computing an integral matching
you're essentially putting all of the
importance you have N squared edges but
you're putting all of the importance on
only n edges and that's going to give
the address here a lot of power because
they can delete the edges that have
importance
so basically you're allowing some edges
to be much more congested with
importance than other edges
so in order to fix this we want our
edges to be less congested we don't want
to place too much importance on any one
Edge and for this we need fractional
matching
and the nice thing about using
fractional matching is that
because of the talk that David gave if
you can solve fractional matching you
immediately get integral matching you
don't need to do anything else so our
goal now is just to maintain a fraction
okay
so and as I said the idea now is going
to be that we're going to try to assign
small fractional value to every Edge so
that there isn't a large impact on that
edge being deleted
so in the complete graph for example
we're going to use the lazy approach
again but our initial matching is going
to just be to put value 1 over n on all
the edges
and so now note that the adversary
needs to delete like Epsilon and value
to ruin your matching but that means
they have to delete Epsilon and squared
edges so they basically have to delete
the whole graph just to ruin your one
matching after they delete Epsilon and
squared edges okay you go again you
compute a different one but now you only
have to do this like
the fractional matching way better than
integral matching
of course the problem is yes in this
example you got to put a small value on
every Edge that might not always be
possible
consider this graph where you basically
have something that looks like a click
up here but then just a few individual
matching edges you have to put value one
on these edges in any maximum matching
these edges have to be important
so what we're going to do is basically
try to capture a way to say that okay
some edges are critical but we're going
to show that only a small number of
edges are critical so we're going to
find a way to determine which edges are
critical and which ones are not and of
course criticality is like you're not
just either critical or not critical
there's a whole Spectrum
so we're going to capture this
criticality
with the notion of a capacity
so what we're going to do is we're going
to put a capacity Kappa on every Edge
and we're basically saying that your
matching is not allowed to put more than
value Kappa on that edge
and so as a subroutine you can solve a
problem or basically let's say I give
you a graph and I give you capacities I
say every Edge is allowed to have at
most Kappa value and I want you to find
a fractional matching
then this is this is just a static
problem and this is easy to solve using
standard matching techniques so
basically what you can do is you can
either find a matching that obeys these
capacities
or you can find the cut that says like
okay on these edges the capacities are
too small and so it's impossible for me
to find a large I'm sorry
I forgot to silence my phone
Okay so
um the way you do this is you could just
convert to a flow problem
and then you could run like blocking
flows or you can just solve it directly
as a matching problem
um so the point is you just check is the
max flow mu with these capacities if not
there must be a cut
you can also formulate this cut directly
as a matching thing but I think it's
easier to think of as a flow cut
Okay so
we're just going to assume that we can
solve the subroutine in linear time we
can only solve an approximate version of
it in linear time but let's say you can
just solve the exact version
okay so here's the idea of the algorithm
again we want to make the capacity small
because we don't want to put a lot of
value on every Edge so we start by just
giving every Edge really tiny capacity
this is laughably Tiny there's no way
you can find the matching with these
capacities they're too small
right even if you put value one over N
squared on every single edge that would
still be a very small matching so the
capacity start too small
and now what you do is you basically ask
or sorry okay the first thing you do is
you just check that the graph has a
large matching
if the matching size initially this is
without capacities is less than mu then
you terminate right that was our that
was our claim you try to either find a
matching the size of mu
or Germany
so if they're matching is smaller
terminal now if the matching is Big then
as we saw before you don't want to just
pick an arbitrary integral matching
that's not robust so instead what you're
going to try to do is you're going to
try to find a matching with these
capacities
so if you find the matching with these
capacities great that's going to be the
matching you're going to use that's kind
of the robust matching
but you probably won't find the matching
with these capacities initially you
definitely want
and so initially this matching or cut
thing is missing no no these capacities
are too small and it's going to give you
a cut
but that cut is giving you information
that cut is basically telling you these
edges are too small because basically
you know the graph has a matching if the
capacities are all one that's this first
step
so if the second step is returning a cut
what that means is we know a matching
exists but it doesn't exist with your
particular capacities so that must mean
that there are some edges that whose
capacity is too small the capacity tells
you what those edges are so you're going
to say okay these edges I'm going to
double them
and this has to terminate it eventually
because once your capacity is all reach
one
you know that there exists so much
so this is kind of just giving you a
targeted way to find the problematic
capacities that are too small and raise
them so it's basically giving you a way
to detect the critical edges in the kind
of simplest greediest algorithm where
you just it tells you which ones are
currently bad and you double them and
you might double many times
so this is just a picture you find your
cut
um one thing I want to highlight here is
if you find your cut some of the edges
crossing the cut might already have
value one you don't double those there's
no reason to ever have capacity more
than one because in matching the
vertices of capacity one so Edge
capacity more than one doesn't help but
you also cross a bunch of these red
edges and you double their capacity
okay
so after you do all this you keep
doubling eventually you get a matching
that does satisfy your capacities and
has a large matching and is large
okay and that's it now you do the lazy
algorithm now you found this special
kind of matching and now you just wait
for a long time yeah
yeah
this is that for every age the
fractional weight will be within a
constant factor of the final capacity
what do you mean by the final capacity
oh oh as in I see so basically you get a
bunch of capacities and then you compute
a matching but it has a fractional
weight which is supposed to be less than
capacity and you're saying is it like
tight with the capacity no I don't think
that's the case I mean we haven't done
that but this is not so refined in
algorithm as in I think for example you
could
I think this will always detect the
critical edges like if an edge is
critical then this will always give it
sufficiently high capacity but there
could be edges that get high capacity
even though they don't really need High
that could happen with this house
because you are doubling the capacity
only when it is telling you that you
need to double the capacity so then you
doubled it and then even sure it turned
out to be very flat interesting wow okay
so again I'm only 90 sure of what I'm
saying we didn't investigate the
particular question but I think when we
try to analyze this though
the problem is that like
you found the whole cut
so it's not I don't think it's the case
that every single edge on the cut is
like um
you know you might only have to increase
some of the edges on the cut not
it's basically the problem and so you
might kind of some Edge might keep
participating in a problematic cut
without itself really being the
problematic Edge
is it also the case that when you
increase the increase just to a certain
level but you didn't know that some of
the edges could go much higher yeah so
some of the other edges will go higher
later and then you don't really need to
go higher exactly yeah exactly yeah so I
I think there's yeah it's only upper the
capacity is only an upper bound
but we'll show the total capacity is
small in the end so it's like it's it's
still pretty close but not on like an
edge by Edge basis just in an aggregate
okay so we do all of this just to
compute a specific static matching
fractional matching that we claim is
robust
and so now we handle deletions in the
lazy way where basically now we have to
wait until Epsilon mu total capacity is
deleted right mu is the size of our
original matching we can wait for up to
Epsilon mu to capacity deletion once
this is deleted we just start a new
phase
so clearly the matching is always large
because we only wait for this much and
what does a new phase mean
well it just means that after this
amount of capacity was deleted we now
again check does the graph still have a
large matching objectively with all
capacities one if yes then if no then we
terminate if it does still have a large
matching then you start again looking
for a matching with this current
capacity and doubling it if it's too
small the only key thing is that the
capacity function Kappa
you kind of reuse the previous capacity
function so you have some capacity
function you delete a bunch of edges so
you deleted too much capacity so you go
again but you stick with the capacity
function you have and you ask okay with
that capacity function
do I still have a large matching and the
answer might be no because some things
were deleted and then you start doubling
but the key thing is that the capacities
are monotonically increasing across all
phases
okay that is
are there any questions about the
algorithm before I do the analysis
search
so I should note it is totally possible
for the adversary for this to happen
pretty quickly you might have some edges
with capacity one and then the adversary
can just delete a small number of edges
and force you to start a new phase
but basically what we're going to show
is that yes if the adversary deletes
critical edges that makes you do a lot
of work but there are only a few
critical edges over the entire sequence
there are a few critical edges and so
this just can't happen that often that
matters
can you just say how you should update
mute I mean probably you never update so
mu is sort of given to you and you're
told you have to either find a matching
of size approximately mu or certify that
non-exist and then you terminate right
so basically in this step if the maximum
matching is less than mu you just
terminate but presumably in a new phase
new gets updated no so this is all just
for one value of mu
that was kind of then like if mu becomes
smaller then you literally restart the
whole algorithm you throw everything
away all the capacities everything and
you just reached that's kind of what I
had on the first slide is that like if
if once your matching size drops by a
lot that can only happen login times
objectively so that's just like log and
different like wide it or like Global
iterations we're just focusing on a
single one where we're told mu use fixed
throughout this whole thing so so
terminate just means that you update you
and you re-initialize cut off is that
correct yeah terminate means you update
mu and you like start the whole thing
from the beginning yeah exactly yeah
uh yeah
ah so the total delayed capacity being
Epsilon mu is not the same as the size
of the matching decreasing exactly so so
yeah that's good so the point is it's
kind of we saw in the complete graph the
adversary can delete your capacity but
there's still a large matching the
reason so it's like that's kind of the
bad case if the adversary actually
deletes if that is whenever say actually
reduces the size of the matching that's
good because that can't happen very
often the bad case is when the adversary
deletes your matching but there still
exists a large matching so now you have
to go spend time recomputing it
and it seems like
at least the iterative thing is trying
to solve like problem of minimizing
volume while ensuring that every card
has sufficient size
but
the critical thing seems to be that
you're starting with this one over N
squared uniform point spread like in the
sense that like the optimal solution to
that like volume minimizing problem is
just a matching the optimal matching
but because they are starting with this
like
uniform solution you seem to get this
entropy directions human properties
right so okay so sorry so are you saying
like
the question yeah I can so I think
you're asking like
I'm not sure I fully understand the
question
so I will do my best but basically
like so there are many optimal matchings
uh but we find a specific one that as
you say kind of um has this like uh is
kind of has high entropy by
um starting with this uniform
distribution
um
I agree it's crucial to start with the
uniform distribution absolutely that is
um we need to do that uh
and the final analysis although we don't
do it this way seems reminiscent of an
entropy analysis so
um
but I think kind of
the main thing we need to prove is sort
of that this
um like we're gonna show the thing is
this also needs to work in a dynamic set
so we're going to show not just that
like
at this stage like after the first time
we do this we can show the total
capacity is relatively small
um but then what we also have to show is
that even after the adversary deletes
edges and we have to do this again and
that is and we do this again the total
capacity is going to remain small
uh and I think that's yeah
right yeah just a recognizing third
question so you can maximize entropy and
that works is there a connection to this
and that should be maximizing I've not
thought about this
I'm really not sure that's kind of a
question I'm going to ask you there's
going to be a part where I say our
analysis a bit ad hoc I bet there is a
more principled way of doing it so
so uh we did show this you can maximize
entropy and it works
wait sorry you're saying you did this
yes yes in okay tell me more we have a
follow-up paper you can maximize entropy
over like fractional matchings and that
has the same deletion property oh that
has the same deletion okay sorry you've
okay that question is
thank you for that question it's too
close it's too close no I'm and I'm
going to ask the same question so okay
thank you I want to hear more uh uh
exactly how you do it
so he basically just I think it'll make
a little bit more sense in a in this I
mean basically what he said is that
another way to I give a way of sort of
I'm trying to compute a particular kind
of matching which is like kind of
catches the critical edges while not
putting too much weight on the
non-critical edges and we're doing this
using this iterative approach and what
Aaron is saying is that you could do
this using a different way by just kind
of maximizing a certain entropy function
it's instead of using an iterated
approach yeah so just say uh if you
compute like an entropy maximized
solution for some notion of that
solves that that problem any solution to
that problem has the property you don't
recompute too many
times okay that's
use the max flow result to solve it and
we give another method to solve it this
is Joint work with a few
yeah I guess not in detailing but just
because you said entropy I thought I had
to make the comment for the video yeah
yeah I mean the repetition sorry is
exactly what I told Valerie is that they
showed that like instead of using this
iterative approach you can compute
something that just like sort of
maximizes the entry fractional matching
that maximizes entropy function and that
will just give you what you want so that
sounds really nice that sounds like a
cleaner way of doing it than what we
would
okay
we can debate whether the methods that
maximize that your gear cleaner right
there are many yeah but anyway
um let's for now we're sticking with
this one
okay so our goal now is to analyze the
running time and in particular what
we're trying to figure out is how many
phases you have
or rather no more specific we're trying
to figure out how often do you call this
function matching your cut because
that's where all the work happens you
kind of you have to call it you have to
keep doubling capacities now maybe after
a while a new phase search you have to
keep calling it again so the question is
how many times do we call it over all
phases
okay
so
this is kind of a high level slide but I
think I've gone through all this we put
it that we're just trying to balance the
congestion and we're using the capacity
to balance the congestion
okay so let's see the time analysis the
key step is to argue that this total
number of doubling steps the overall
phases that we have to double the
capacity is only like log n
okay so let me form let me formalize
this a bit here's how we're going to do
it
so as I said capacity is monotonically
increasing and that's really crucial and
so we're going to Define this function
that's formally monotonically increasing
K all
where basically
we want to be monotonically increasing
but edges get deleted and so to still be
monotonically increasing we're going to
define the capacity even for a deleted
Edge so when an edge gets deleted that
sort of its capacity is frozen but it's
still contributing to chaol so this way
Edge deletions don't decrease capacity
okay and now it's clear our capacity
function only increases because all we
ever do is double capacities
so
what can we say about chaos well
there's the initial capacity which is
very small
and now
every time we do a doubling step we
increase the capacity but how much do we
increase the capacity well we increase
it by the size of the cut but the size
of the cut must have been less than mu
otherwise it would have been a matching
this was a cut certifying we don't have
a matching up size mute so the cut has
size less than mu so when you double it
you increase the capacity by mu so every
time you double you increase the
capacity by most mu so the total amount
of a capacity increase is the number of
doubling steps times mu so if we accept
this kilometer for now
then the total capacity ever is that
most of mu login
so let's accept the kilima and see that
this basically finishes the analysis of
our algorithm
which is that our total so we know our
total capacity is Mu login
so what is the number of faces well the
adversary has to delete Epsilon mu
in order to cause a new phase
so what that means is that the number of
phases is only log n
so what is the total time well
basically every time
during a new phase we have to call
matching a cut to figure out you know is
there matching or is there cut and also
every time we double we didn't find the
matching so we have to call matching or
cut but both of these are just log n
and the time to find the map static
matching or cut is just linear so our
running time is like M log n
so given the kilometer that's the whole
analysis
there are no questions
the next step is proving the key level
yeah
is there is there some reason to believe
that the dependence on Epsilon is tight
no I don't think so and I think you guys
improve the dependent setups right
that's uh we have like login over
Epsilon squared V computations if I ever
call right and then since it's an
entropy problem we can like since the
problem is like a
like clearly specified decoupled
optimization problem we can just like
invoke the Maxwell result and solve it
so you just solve in them in almost in
your time I see I see so so you got
login over Epsilon squared is the total
unlock like M bunch of subpolynomial
factors over Epsilon squared us the
total time it's a total time uh I see
whereas we're getting another like Cube
Factor yes it saves two epsilons okay at
the cost of this right
um I'm also like not 100 I think this is
right but yeah
um I but you have to write but then you
have to this is like for one value of mu
so there we add additional Epsilon so we
don't optimize but yeah they get it done
better
okay
so
um it remains to prove the key level
so let's do that
so we want to prove that the total
number of doubling steps is like log n
so yeah I think it's a nice proof
uh it's not complicated it does feel a
bit ad hoc and so I had this whole thing
of can we do a better proof it sounds
like that problem has been resolved so
there is a better proof but you're gonna
hear the slightly
foreign
okay so here it is so
what we want to claim is that
um after if you keep doubling capacities
and you still can't find the matching
with those capacities that means they're
just objectively is no larger matching
left anymore like even with capacity one
and then you can term it but basically
after you double enough times your
capacities are big enough so if you
can't find a matching
it must not exist
so how are we going to argue this
we're going to use a potential function
based on mean cost matching
so let's have some definitions
so I'm going to set the cost of an edge
to be basically log of the capacity
times an unsquare to keep everything
possible
and then
just consider the set of all integral
matchings so the potential function is
just going to be on integral matching
the potential function doesn't care
about capacities
the only reason it cares about
capacities is because they influence
costs but the matching themselves are
going to be integral
and then the potential is just the
minimum cost batching
so again these matchings are integral
they don't respect capacities but
capacities influence them because low
capacity edges are getting lower cost so
essentially the potential is trying to
find a matching that's using low-cost
edges or in other words it's using low
capacity
see some nice properties of this
potential function
so
okay every Edge has cost at most log n
because the capacities are most one
and so you get log n as the cost
so even any matching you pick just has
cost mu login Max matching size is Mu so
the potential is always at most when you
log n
and now we have a standard potential
argument it's upper bounded for this
reason
um yeah so this was saying every
matching has capacity uh every Edge has
cost at most
uh well again
so the total cost is Mu login
a note in particular that capacities are
less than one so that's why every Edge
has cost that most login
okay so we finish this
we know that we have an upper bound on
the potential function we know that it
starts bigger than or equal to zero
because initially our costs are all
positive
only increases because we only double
capacity so we only increase costs
okay
so the final step is to say that every
time you do a doubling step you increase
the potential bylaw clearly these three
things together give us what we need
so let's go ahead and do this
so
let's do this step
okay so we want to claim that every time
you double the potential increases by a
lot
the proof is quite simple which is just
so let's look at this cut
and consider any matching and I'm going
to claim that this matching uses a lot
of these red edges and so when you
increase the cost of these red edges the
cost of your matching goes up so I'm
going to prove this for any matching
that for any matching
any maximum matching it's cost must go
up
as a result of this doubling step
so pick any arbitrary matching
so it's enough to show that this
matching intersects a lot with these red
edges because those red edges when you
double them they're capacity their cost
decreases by one right because cost is
log of capacity
so if the matching has a lot of uses a
lot of those red edges then and you
increase all of their costs then the
cost of the matching must increase
so we just need to show that any maximum
matching uses a lot of red edges and
this just follows from the definition of
cut which is basically that the red
edges are everything that's not the blue
edges
so the claim is that just the blue edge
is enough would not allow you to have a
large matching because this is by
definition a cut
right we know that all of these blue
edges together
are at most the capacity of the cut
which is at most it's like 1 minus 10
Epsilon mu because your cut is
certifying that you don't have a
matching of size one minus 10 Epsilon
View
on the other hand we know that the
matching you're finding has to have size
1 minus Epsilon View
that's how we're looking at specifically
matchings with this large side so we're
basically exploiting a slack we have
and so that remaining nine Epsilon that
nine Epsilon mu that has to come from
the red edges this was a small cut uh so
um yeah a lot of its value has to come
from the red edges
and that's it
those rather just increase in cost
and so your overall potential increases
okay that's it that's the whole analysis
so are there questions about this last
part
if the algebra isn't making sense again
the argument is just that this was a cut
so what it means for it to be a cut is
that
um the
its total capacity was not very big so
there can't be that many one edges on it
it must be that the reason this capacity
wasn't that big is because it's using a
bunch of these red edges that have low
capacity
and now you're increasing their capacity
so you're increasing the cost
the bottom line it should be if looking
at the ones that aren't in
oh well you're right no yes you're right
that's minus never mind I think it's
that yeah
or M Prime intersected the cup
like The crucial thing should have made
intersection somewhere
this the thing that's just crucial
no this is
okay I think it's correct uh but I also
don't think it's worth going through
yeah
okay
the whole second thing I'm Gonna Wanna
cover we'll see how much time there is
for that
okay
so to summarize the basic approaches are
going to be lazy we're going to compute
a matching and then wait for that to
show you to delete things but
um the problem is that if you just pick
an arbitrary matching you're kind of
condensing all of your importance on a
small number of edges and congestion
balancing describes that importance out
great so
this is basically a Showcase of the
technique relatively simple and now I
want to show how we use the technique
inside kind of a larger more complicated
problem in particular rather than using
it to maintain a matching we're going to
use it to maintain an extender Witness
okay so that was the end of that part of
the talk
how much time do I have left
okay not so bad including this including
questions okay let's see how much we can
get through
true but probably have more okay let's
Breeze through the problem then that we
want to Define okay so single search
artist paths
you have a graph
Source you want to maintain distances
from the source
so in the static case this is easy to
solve
what about in the dynamic case
so fully Dynamic
um is hard I'm not going to go through
this but basically you can show it fully
Dynamic is hard so people turn to the
decremental case
um and you know some motivations are
detrimental uh are the ones we've all
we've gone through many times in the
seminar uh and one is that we can use
this as a subroutine in sorry in many
static algorithms oh no no yeah we can
use it as a subroutine in Dynamic
algorithms but also in the static
okay so what was known about this
problem so let's just take the simple
search and we have an unweighted graph
so each update just deletes an edge so
we start with some graph G and we end
with an empty graph
so basically the trivial thing is to
recompute single searches from scratch
after every deletion takes M times M
deletion that's M squared total time
there's a classic Improvement down to MN
and there's conditional lower bound
showing this optimal for the exact case
so we turn to the approximate case
what can you do if you allow approximate
distances
okay so this is the problem each update
deletes an edge we want to maintain
approximate distances
so this is a problem that was there are
like many many papers on this problem
like this was the classic Dynamic
problem for a while uh in 2014 it was
largely settled
um so this is uh Sebastian Monica
tanyapan they showed you can get
almost linear total update time so the
same basically the same amount of time
it takes to compute just a single
shortest path tree
they can maintain a shortest Passover
the whole sequence of deletions
so this is great it has one problem
though which is that it is only works
against a non-adaptive address
and yeah sorry I lost track of something
basic is this directed or undirected to
us undirected yes undirected undirected
uh
so if you want an Adaptive algorithm if
you want an algorithm that works against
adaptive batter shade this problem
becomes much harder so there was kind of
the solo part that tried to improve it
but you could see it's very far from
almost linear
so our result is to get almost linear
so this is a nice data structure now
that you can just sort of plug it in
anywhere as a black box it's
deterministic so we'll work in a static
settings so this I think finally
concludes the problem except for the
fact Okay so
um and one nice thing about this is
again you can plug it into data
structures
and in particular at the time we were
excited because this got an approximate
the first like approximately algorithm
in almost linear time that result is
totally obsolete now
um
but it's still it's a nice data
structure I think we'll find other uses
so for example currently it's being used
for fast construction of commercial
juice
so it's kind of makes sense to use in a
lot of flow type settings
okay so what I want to do is not tell
you the whole result but narrow down on
one part of the result and talk about
that part because I think it's the most
interesting part and also because we
solve it using congestion modes
so again this is the problem
but I'm going to quickly change the
problem to talk about a very specific
Cube
so at an extremely high level if you
look at almost all the fast algorithms
of this problem adaptive non-adaptive
they're all at some level
breaking the graph up into a bunch of
low diameter balls because evidential
arteries works well for low diameter
bombs
so
um this is a highly informal claim but
there they are all at some level doing
just this
so as a static problem it's easy to
cover a graph with low diameter balls
but dynamically it's kind of hard to
cover a graph of flow diameter balls and
in particular even the following really
simple thing turns out to be hard which
is let's say I give you a low diameter
ball I tell you this is low diameter you
verify it
and now I start deleting edges and all
you have to do is just maintain a low
diameter core inside that ball
or say this ball is no longer low
diameter
so let's formalize that
so just some basic definitions in
particular
um we're going to be using an unweighted
graph for this talk and when I talk
about diameter I mean weak diameter but
it doesn't really matter
so here's the problem that I just tried
to formalize so here instead of solving
starting with a particular ball of low
diameter I'm going to simplify it even
more let's just say you start with the
whole graph has low diameter initially
so I'm going to draw this on the board
you start with a graph
it has low diameter
now you delete some edges
and some small parts of the graph might
now be further away
but most of the graph is still low
diameter so in this case you basically
you still have a low diameter core that
contains most of your graph and you just
have a small number of vertices that are
no longer part of your low diameter
but eventually you might delete a lot of
edges and your whole graph will
decompose into like three parts of size
n over three or something like this with
you know long paths between them and
this no longer has a low diameter core
this is really fully decomposed and then
you have to say it's decomposed so
basically your goal is to either
maintain this core that still has a
little diameter or say no no this is
decomposed I'm done
that's going to be the whole problem so
let's write that down here
of the stronger
so we start with our initial low
diameter graph we want to maintain a
large set K that still has a low
diameter with some slack we could allow
some polynomial Slack
and we want this to be large we want it
to be like at least half the vertices
and basically we're going to terminate
when there when there is no large core
anymore and so formally we're going to
terminate when at least one percent of
the vertices are scattered so what I
mean by scattered is like basically one
of your one percent of your vertices are
like this you're allowed to terminate so
you only have to maintain the core if
really almost everybody's still in the
floor so formally a Vertex is scattered
basically just means that the ball
around that vertex is missing a constant
fraction
so that's important
probably want to talk about it so this
is all happening under Edge deletion
so why do we care about this problem
of low diameter is there exists a vertex
uh
uh sorry there exists a Vertex for which
the ball around it contains at least
half or all vertices
no so you're maintaining you're
explicitly maintaining the low diameter
set k
I'm going to insert the below diameter
is just any two vertices how about this
yeah
so the reason I bring up this problem
I think that it
basically distills a building block
that's common to many of the previous
they don't Define a problem like robust
core and they're usually doing something
more complicated so you might not see it
this way but I think in essence they all
have to in one way or another implicitly
solve this problem because they're all
breaking up the graph into low diameter
balls and at the end of the day you have
to keep track of is this ball still low
diameter or do I have to throw it away
and recompute because it's decomposed
like this
so basically our result is in two parts
first we show how to solve this problem
because this distilled problem the
reason it's important is because it's
common to all these other algorithms but
it turns out to be really hard in the
Adaptive setting and so our main
contribution is we show how to solve it
the second we do thing we do is kind of
motivating my claim that this is the
essence of a lot of the algorithms in
that
they basically show like the existing
algorithms use many different
complex sophisticated techniques which
are all necessary
basically what we show is that at the
end of the day the hard part
specifically about adaptive adversaries
is this robust core problem so we
basically say like if you just have a
building if you have a black box just
for robust core then you can use all
these other techniques that people have
developed
to transform this robust core algorithm
into an algorithm for the general
problem and all of this works just fine
so basically you need all of these
techniques
but the the
the hard part about additivity is not
for many of these techniques the hard
part is just here just in robust core
and so we kind of managed to single out
that one part that's hard for adaptive
adversaries and now our goal is to solve
it
okay so let's quickly talk about
previous attempts to solve this problem
again other papers don't do so
explicitly but implicitly they are
solving this problem
and so I said that okay this problem
robust core is hard is the hard part for
adaptive adversaries and in particular
it's actually really easy within
oblivious adversary so the algorithm I'm
low on time so I'll just quickly say it
is basically you pick a random Source in
your graph and you maintain a ball
around your random source and that ball
that just is your core so you have your
graph you pick a random Source initially
your graph has low diameter so the ball
around the random source is the whole
graph
eventually that ball might lose some
vertices but you just maintain that
random ball
at some point your ball might become too
small
and so at this point maybe it's because
maybe your random Source has become your
ball has become too small because your
random source is here
and the graph is decomposed and in that
case you can terminate
but it's possible that your random
Source was here and so the ball around
the random Source became too small but
there still is a low diameter component
so in that case you basically have to
start from scratch with a new random
Source you're not done yet you still
have a core you just happen to pick the
wrong source and so now you have to go
again
and the analysis exploits the fact that
the source is random
so basically
if what we can say for sure is that you
had to restart because your ball around
s wasn't big enough so s is scattered
but s was picked randomly so if s is
scattered that means an expectation half
the vertices are scattered so an
expectation you're allowed to stop
you're allowed to stop on half the
vertices are scared and the high
probability you can stop after log n of
these random sources
so basically picking a single random
source and maintaining a ball around it
is efficient using like a classic
Evolution archery and you only have to
do this few times because you picked the
source of Random
I think thatchup all talked about this
in his boot camp the sort of the power
of the random Source technique is that
true yeah well anyway this is somehow
um
the thing about this technique is it
works really if there's a really simple
solution against a non-adaptive
adversary but it totally fails against
an Adaptive adversary because the
adversary can figure out your Source
they can sort of use queries easily to
figure out which your source is and so
basically you pick a source and all the
adversary is going to do is it's going
to delete only the edges around that
source
and so
um your graph is still looks basically
the same as before like a source another
shade just deletes the edges just around
the source so the graph is essentially
the same as before but all of your work
was for nothing because your Source got
destroyed and you have to pick a new
source and you have to keep going and so
in the end the adversary can basically
force you to pick every vertex as a
source so this is very inefficient again
so there's the simple trick so basically
what we did is we distilled the problem
down to this one part robust core that's
hard for an Adaptive adversary and that
one core part you can really see the
difference there's this simple trick
that works so well against a
non-adaptive adversary that completely
fails against adapters and I think the
simple trick is actually like it's not
just for this problem I think there are
a lot of problems where Dynamic problems
where you know they use Randomness in
various ways but if you really distill
it a lot of the randomness can be made
adaptive or gotten rid of and the really
it all boils down to this trick I think
there are a lot of algorithms where
essentially this trick is the reason
that it only works against someone
okay we don't have a black box way to
make this trick adaptive but we can do
it for this problem
so that's what we're going to do
okay so I'm going to skip this part
um
okay so here's how we solve this problem
how much time do I have Sebastian
ten minutes okay
okay
so
here's how we're going to solve a robust
core
so for this we're going to use vertex
expanders
so let me Erase here
I'll just
visited
yeah this works for weighted but we're
gonna assume unweighted for the talk
everything works for weighted
so a Vertex expander is so basically if
you have a graph
and you pick any set l
it's expansion anival is basically just
all the vertices that L is adjacent to
so this will be unavailable
and we say that a graph is a vertex
expander if for every set l n of L is
relatively big compared to L like within
a log Factor
so for this talk I'm only going to talk
about vertex expanders for those of you
are used to Edge expanders and the
expansion Factor let's just say it's
always around one of our logs
so why vertex expanders what why why why
am I suddenly talking about expanders
okay one nice thing about expanders is
they always have low diameter so if you
can maintain you want to maintain this
low diameter core if you can just
maintain a chord that's a Vertex
expander that's going to be your low
diameter core foreign
we want to use vertex expanders which is
that they are robust to Edge deletions
and I think this here it's worth having
a contrast
so this is here is a low diameter graph
so it looks like this
you have two cliques connected by a
single edge
this graph is low diameter but it's very
not robust to Edge Solutions in that if
the adversary deletes this one Edge
suddenly your whole graph decomposes
an expander however cannot have this so
if you have an expander and the
adversary deletes a small number of
edges
it might be the case that that deletion
causes a small part of the expander to
stop being expansive to leave but it
cannot ruin the whole expander it cannot
ruin half the expander
so they're robust
so I'm going to formalize that with this
notion of pruning
which is basically that if you have a
graph
the Civics vertex expander and you start
deleting edges then you can always
maintain a large core inside the graph
that's still an expander and you can do
that for up to like n over log n Edge
deletion so you can process a lot of
edge Solutions and still have a large
expense
by the way for those of you who like
work with this a lot the reason we can
only handle n edges and not m is because
so this is a nice reason to use vertex
expanders is that if you start with a
Vertex expander you kind of keep having
one for a long time and that's going to
be good for being lazy
so
to see the power vertex expanders let's
assume that our graph is initially a
Vertex expander and then think about how
we would solve this problem
so in that case all we're going to do is
we start with a graph that's a Vertex
expander
and our core is just going to be we're
going to maintain
that
set X
pruning is going to tell us that we can
always maintain a large expander inside
our original expander even as I just are
deleted
so we maintain our large expander X at
some point x gets too small
and then we have to restart
but the point is that this restart only
happens after like another log
animations
so prone of G is your prune is just a
subroutine that maintains a large
expander if you start with an expander
it maintains a large expander inside it
even through deletion so it's
maintaining this prune is just returning
the set X
okay so we have to be a little careful
here because so what do we do when we
restart well now that we've deleted
edges the graph might not be a Vertex
expander anymore
so you can't really use this anymore but
let's even make the stronger assumption
that the graph is just always a Vertex
expander until you have to terminate
so basically you just all you have to do
is just you maintain keep track of is
the graph still a Vertex expander or has
it been destroyed and I can terminate
and in this case you could just like
uh you maintain your set X eventually
becomes too small because the pruning
algorithm stops working and so now you
basically have to start from scratch and
again like look at the whole graph if
it's not a Vertex expander anymore you
can terminate if it is you just go again
you again start pruning and maintain a
setbacks
so essentially what this is doing is
everywhere we're in the non-adaptive
case you maintain the ball around the
random source
that's no longer going to be robust
against adaptive adversary so you
replace that ball with an expense
okay so this is the ideal Eye Center if
you always have a Vertex expander then
you can get an efficient algorithm
because because you can use pruning and
because pruning is robust to a large
number of deletions
okay is this actually efficient though
let's do the analysis
so you start with a Vertex expander
um and the algorithm is you can use
pruning to always maintain a large
expander X inside of your vertex
expander and this is robust up to n over
log and deletions and then you have to
restart
so to compute to sort of run the pruning
algorithm takes linear time and you have
to recompute every n over log n
deletions and this is not looking great
this is good in a sparse graph but it's
bad intense graphs
okay so this is supposed to be the
idealized scenario where G is just
always a Vertex expander and even this
turns out to be kind of annoying
so to solve this this is a kind of a
very standard application actually
congestion balancing this is our
original paper of congestion balancing
this is basically the problem we
introduced it for
which is that
this was a trivial easy algorithm which
is that you just maintain this expander
X and it's robust and deletions and you
have to recompute it
and the problem is that how do you
actually mean how do you do pruning
basically the intuition is I won't go
into details you maintain something
called an expander Witness
which has like n edges
and that's kind of a witness that you
still have a large part that you still
have this large part that's a vertex
the problem is that your graph is M
edges but your witness has n edges and
so the addresser can just delete
this is exactly what we saw the problem
was with matching then you have many
edges but your solution has few edges so
if you just use an integral solution the
adversary can easily just delete your
solution unfortunately
so instead we're going to maintain a
fractional expander with this and again
we're gonna we're gonna try to have
every Edge not be used Too Much using
the capacity cap
and now we can show that this is robust
again the adversary has to delete n over
log n to ruin your witness but they have
to delete n over log n fractional value
and so you can use congestion balancing
to ensure that the total fractional
value is small and I'm not going to go
into details but it's really almost
exactly the same as the analysis I gave
for matching
and except that now the potential
functions that are being Min cost
matching is min cost expander Witness
but it's very similar
okay so let me just in the last few
minutes say okay all of that was to
solve the idealized case so this was
kind of from a this was still from the
matching paper
the problem is that this only works on
an expander so you need congestion
balancing even in the idealized case
when the graph is an expander but what
if the original graph is not an expanded
expander our input robust core just
guaranteed the initial graph a small
diameter but it might not ever look like
an expander
so the first thing you might try is
expanded decomposition
it's really unclear how to use this
efficiently you can use it to get like
some improvements but
um expanded decomposition you have to
build a whole hierarchy we could not
actually figure out how to make it
efficient
um instead we kind of argue that you
don't need expanded decomposition and I
only have two minutes so let me just
kind of give the highlight
which is that
let's look at some graphs
and again try to get the notion of
critical vertices just like we had with
matching so instead of edges it's going
to be vertices
so basically an edge is critical if
deleting that edge can cause you to
decompose a lot so in this graph this
Edge is very critical
so in an expander no edges are critical
that's what it means to be an expander
it's robust Edge deletions don't do much
in a pass graph here
the basically all the middle vertices
are critical if you delete any of these
vertices if you delete any of the edges
around these vertices you decompose
[Music]
in this graph here the middle Edge is
critical the parts right around that are
critical but everything else is
non-critical if you delete that just
around here you have basically no impact
and so
one thing to note is that this graph
everything is critical but this is a
large diameter graph
this graph actually very few things are
critical and what we're able to show is
that in any low diameter graph you have
very few critical vertices and the way
we compute criticality is by using
congestion model thing so I'm going to
skip everything but basically we
um you you define a notion of a
capacitated expander so now you're an
expander with respect to capacities
and the main difference is now
capacities are bigger than one so you're
basically saying these vertices if I
kind of count these vertices as n
vertices then if I look at this cut I
have n over two vertices on this side I
have only one vertex on this side but if
I count this vertex as having
multiplicity n then it's still
technically an expanded so we're
basically saying can I increase some of
my vertex weights in order for things to
be an expander
and what we're able to show is that
using congestion balancing you can
figure out what the weights on every
vertex should be and you can figure out
that you can prove that in a low
diameter graph most of your vertices
will still have low weight and you only
have a few critical vertices
and so then the idea of the algorithm is
when the adversary deletes critical
vertices that causes you to do a lot of
work but we can use congestion balancing
to argue that you have fewer numbers
and now out of
time so I'll just stop at this slide
thank you everyone we have time for a
few questions
maybe I don't have a question but put a
comment maybe for everyone who's
interested interested in this um this uh
robust k core problem that you mentioned
I think in my opinion the cleanest way
where it appears at exactly as exactly
that problem with exactly that algorithm
I think that's uh
the low diameter
um low stretched tree paper in in seoula
a few years ago are they also Armenian
exactly this and with a very nice
cool thanks
oh
so so the analysis for the matching
looks similar to some parallel algorithm
for parallel multiplicative weight
update algorithm for
Max matching
so is there any Formal Connection it
looks very similar to what you would do
if you want okay
can you say more about how it's similar
I mean typically if you have a packing
integer a packing problem and you won't
find a parallel algorithm you start with
some 1 over n and you kind of
I mean
here you're using kind of a blocker for
the thing rather than but there are
parallel algorithms which do similar
things they double
all the values which have low gradient
or whatever it is yeah yeah so they take
login
iterations and that's it's very similar
I think the analysis also
yeah I should I just think trying to
make a connection not
John I agree it's similar and that's
kind of why I felt like we're probably
Reinventing the wheel in some sense like
there's probably like a princess wave a
principled way of doing this in terms of
existing
um
in some Concepts but it's like different
enough that we couldn't figure out how
to analyze it
I wouldn't be Sur
prised
foreign
[Applause]